but when asked about it check this out
we have an article the Seattle mayor
says she doesn't know how long Chazz
occupation will continue Seattle mayor
Jenny Durkin jokingly said we could have
a Summer of Love when asked how long
Seattle's police free zone could remain
in place you know you know what I love
about jazz it's it's it's they conquered
it right okay they're colonizers mm-hmm
they found land that was already owned
and occupied they came in with rocks
bottles and guns
sounds familiar set up walls to keep out
undesirables and then declared it was
their town checkpoints yep and yet
already figure patrol border patrol mini
police state I love it
yeah man warlord dictator what I was
trying to explain to people like Occupy
Wall Street mm-hmm they don't actually
want to change the system
no they just wants to own it yep they
want to be on top of the system so a
piece of the pie apparently there was a
tweet going around where somebody tried
to create an autonomous zone inside yes
what was that all about
I don't know see that's what you would
have done that's what you were just
saying Oh totally
so you I would have tried to make your
own little hill I lived in a building
okay if I lived in a building this book
inside mine I would I would block off my
sidewalk and say don't come near me I
live here okay and you're conky you're
the conquerors coming to steal my land
bigoted colonizer and I would scream
colonizer in their faces if I kept and I
would just scream it top of my lungs you
ever see those videos where there's like
a viral video right now where these cops
are trying to talk to some woman yes
I've seen and then she just goes and the
cops are like bye and they used to walk
there which one I know what you know
let's just talk about that for a second
what is with these people who think oh I
I don't like what you're saying I am now
going to scream at you on the top of my
lungs over and over and over again these
how is that your argument how is that
logical I don't what I so listen man
when I was when I was little I I when I
was little
younger I got arrested skateboarding and
you know that I did when they went to
arrest me what do they do they walk up
grabbed my arm unit I did as soon as I
grabbed my arm ma put my hands behind my
back
they sat me down the team in cuffs they
said you're under arrest and I said
nothing smart I was just like for what
and they were like you know something I
don't know they said something stupid it
makes sense and the cops came and I just
didn't say anything okay and then they
tried giving me a felony what yup was
they said it was criminal damage to
federal property because I was
skateboarding downtown Chicago yes and
so when when when when it came time to
actually go through processing the cops
were like one cop was like me caning me
with this dude he's like give him damage
to a state-supported location or
something which is a misdemeanor okay
and then when I finally went to court
the judge looked and he goes he like
they called my name you know looks and
he goes excuse me what is this like I
don't know who spoke up it was a the DA
order a DA or whatever yeah and they
were like the defendant was
skateboarding in downtown Chicago and
then he goes are you kidding me yeah he
goes get out of my courtroom and then he
said like Sol or whatever I don't know
it meant it was like they're just
disregarding it but they could bring it
back if they want to know that happened
to me I just walked out same was the
reason I bring this up though like a lot
of the protest stuff that we're seeing
look at what you did you see what they
did when a guy got accused of theft
who's they the chest they surrounded the
dude it started screaming what did you
do what did you do and he's saying I
didn't do anything I don't do anything I
said why did you run why did you run and
someone's holding a baseball bat oh my
gosh listen man hmm you do not want to
be accused by a mob who can't prove
anything
yeah because they'll just start whaling
on you like when that rasz dude if only
there was something like checks and
bounces and like a system that is in
place to handle that kind of stuff you
know what I've noticed in a lot of these
videos what and I know I'm gonna get
accused of privilege and all that other
stuff man but let me just start by
saying mixed-race family South Side
Chicago
spare me and shove it when the cop would
walk up to me and start talking I
wouldn't talk to him you know I just be
like I got nothing to say and if they
pressed me or detained me am I being
detained
and if I got arrested you know what I
did I got arrested a couple times you
shut up you put your hands behind you
back and you deal with it when you can
screaming and fighting and saying for
what for what for what all that doesn't
this is this is what I see in a lot of
these videos the cops will walk up and
they'll be like what are you doing and
then the people will be like you can't
talk to me
I can do it and then now you're fighting
with the cops yeah then the cops will be
like show me your ID and then they give
them you know they badmouth yeah okay I
get it man the cops can't do some of
these things the cops are allowed to
detain you for a brief period they're
allowed to detain you and trying to
ascertain your identify whatever some of
these I think are some of these stops
you seen these videos yeah a complete BS
but I got to tell you what a lot of
these videos people resist for no reason
in stupid ways and so you know what I
was told when I was little when so when
I was like 14 I had I was basically
assaulted by the security guard of this
carnival sitting in my friend's house he
came up to my friend's house are telling
us to leave I guess he thought that we
were like carnival room the carnival
yeah but we weren't we were like Memphis
might wasn't my friend was in my house
he's like I don't care leave and he's
like what no it's my house so the guy
grabbed me and started poking me calling
me stupid and whatever so I was like I
think I was like 14 I called my dad and
said the guy grabbed me and like left a
mark yeah turns out the guy was a
retired cop and so what happened was
when the police showed up they walked up
and said they walked it we watched him
walk up to the retired cop start
laughing shake his hand the guy who
assaulted me walked up to me and said so
do you want to get arrest for
trespassing or do want to go home now
and we were like what my dad was like
we'll leave and then as we're leaving my
dad was really angry yeah and he's like
we're gonna go file a complaint with
internal affairs and I was like but
that's just it he gets away with it and
he goes yep because in the real world
you got to choose your battles do you
want to spend the next three or four
days dealing with bad cops we're gonna
mess with you and or are you gonna walk
away use your time properly and not get
into a fight with people who happen to
be bad and abusing the system that is
smart so he filed a complaint no the end
of it and they probably got away with it
and you know what it sucks but I learned
something that day my dad said choose
your battles yes because you might feel
your justify you might feel your right
but they they have power and they will
use it and you got to be smart about how
you respond so later in my life when I
got arrested I
shut up let him do their thing and then
afterwards I win that's it a lot of
people under these situations thinking I
I'm high and mighty you can't do this
this is America whatever
it's like bro they can lie and people
will side with them I'm not saying it
should be this way I'm saying if you
don't realize what the game is and you
try and enter this because you think
you're better and you think you'll win
you're an idiot you ever see that video
are the two guys are alike it's like
they're like I don't know Italians or
whatever and they're like what do you do
when a cop talks to you shut them up and
that's like they keep saying it over and
over gonna tulare astir what if a cop
says where you from shut them up what if
he says what'd you have for lunch you
shut them up and there's another video
where guys like if you're ever stopped
by a cop you say I don't answer
questions that's it nothing else they
ask you again I don't answer questions
so you got to understand why the system
is in place there were there was like
this thing written up by a Supreme Court
justice talking about why you never talk
to law enforcement ever under any
circumstances period and people don't
get it they think that oh but I'm not a
suspect so I can help them out you don't
know if you're a suspect or not that's
true and then they can use whatever
against you so you know man I've been
contacted by law enforcement over the
past several years I just ignore I'm not
gonna talk to you sorry man you guys
created this lopsided system this is
this is how the game is played
anyway without going off on too much of
a tangent at least you have recourse
right well everything you just said
proves that that the police department
needs a reform I mean they agree yeah
that is right even a question we all
believe that but but listen listen the
reason I bring that up is to point out
that you might not like the fact that
cops use arrests as punishment they do
that in New York City you know they do
they know that they can arrest you for
anything and make up whatever they want
and then the charges will be dropping
you'll be let up in two days or whatever
but they know that's punishment to you
and they know people are scared of it it
was a big problem during Occupy Wall
Street they literally just snatched
someone up they I've watched I watched
them pull up in cars and just grab a guy
and they were like what yep so yeah the
definitely needs to be reformed for sure
absolutely but you know that doesn't
need to be the abolition of the police
department because they have problems
because
what ends up happening is you see this
video where they surround a guy
screaming at them like a bunch of morons
who can't prove nothing and have no idea
what happened but they have a feeling
well someone said it's him and then you
get you get your teeth knocked out by
some loser thanks for doing nothing yeah
at the very least what I'm saying is
right now you have mob justice or you
have mm a pretty crummy system not the
worst in the world but it's got some
problems right actually I'd say it's
really it's relatively good compared to
like most other countries okay so when I
got arrested and they lied I won in the
end and I got jammed up and it took me a
long time and I to spend money I didn't
have and it was a the skateboarding one
was was nothing I got you know falsely
arrested her it a false arrest because
the riding a skateboarding on the
Chicago is like a petty offense but they
wanted to make an example of
skateboarders I guess so they decided to
lock me up overnight and that was the
worst of it then I had to take off a day
of work or something go to court yeah
and it cost me money yeah and the judge
threw it out if I heard screaming and
saying you know you can't do this to me
you're lying blah blah blah and fighting
with them they would have added on a ton
of ridiculous charges and then I would
have been jammed up for a lot longer so
you have your choice between this is
this up policing was for me in Chicago I
could choose that or I could choose a
bunch of angry pitchfork wielding you
know mobs to go around smashing windows
and screaming in my face about what I
did wrong cuz they know they know cuz
someone said I'll take my chances with
the cops and try and work on reform yeah
and Chaz's existed for what four days
five days now and it's there Ortiz in
every clearing mob justice yep yeah
that's great
it's worse in every regard over there
yeah it's like a scary place and and you
know the problem is I'm sure there are
people who live there who are unhappy I
know but isn't scared but they can't say
anything yeah they're scared if they say
anything the activists will find out
I'll call them bigots white supremacists
wherever they'll lose their jobs yeah
but they got to do it man if I was there
I kind of wish I did I kind of wish it I
kind of wish I had a place oh I do are
you nuts I love it
no I wouldn't yes I would I don't
believe you you're wrong you're not
upset wrong wrong you're telling me I'm
wrong for not believing you yes
okay absolutely nice dude you are 100 my
belief is my belief I traveled the world
but going into places like this on
purpose for a decade yeah believe I
believe that and I will absolutely enjoy
yeah these people trying to get up in my
business and block down my building and
tell me what I can or can't do this is
me laughing at you for not saying notes
and my beliefs well yeah you weren't you
and you you haven't you have a fact list
non backed up opinions on what I've done
with my life and what I would want and
what I would do so it seems to me
ridiculous that you would try and claim
I wouldn't enjoy something I literally
did for a decade I'm saying I'm just
saying I don't believe that you would
that I would what enjoy it absolutely
would I know you're saying it yep okay
well you're wrong completely wrong I
would enjoy it I'm telling you right now
I would and I would I
I would fully went not an Occupy Wall
Street I went to the west coast for
their occupations I went to Egypt I went
to Ukraine I went to Venezuela I went to
Morocco I went to Brazil I went Turkey I
went to all these countries to see
exactly what they were doing and get on
the ground and experience what was going
on if I live there I'd be very very
happy and then you got the van out there
I do for ya I'm working on something
else right now okay if they occupied my
street mmm-hmm I'd have a go of it I'd
say I'd walk up and tell the people
blocking the barricades I in in in less
friendly terms move and don't come back
period who are you I'm the guy who lives
right there yeah end of story and then I
would and if they wanted to assert their
Chaz eNOS and I live there yeah their
chassis loses the chairs autonomous zone
all black well I'll tell you what buddy
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to beat the crap out of me to stop me
from taking this space as mine end of
story
you can't come into my place colonizer
and take my home away from me yeah I'd
point the finger at all the stupid white
lefties who think they have a right to
take the land away from the people who
actually live there now let's be real
though I think most these people they
live in Seattle they're in Capitol Hill
it's a hipster neighborhood yeah they're
probably dancing in their little
sundresses and having a good time and
going to pay rent anymore we could just
tent in this in this grassy area yeah
but the people who live in the buildings
are probably like clapping and happy
no I don't know about that I think so I
think the the businesses might be upset
over the attempts at shaking him down
mm-hmm but dude I I lived in Seattle
briefly I'd hang out in Capitol Hill
those people like I've been to this park
these people are their third hipsters
man I said that's what they look like
right this is right up their alley it's
probably why it's allowed to stay there
right now because no one's complaining
it's a threat
there's no locals to be like hey you
know well they're out of here they're
not burning the city down that's what
governor's probably like how good let
him just have that spot so they they
stop burning down the city there was
there was something funny that happened
though there was some women from the
African American Council oh gods or
something from the local they likley
aides at the police okay showed up and
complained that these people were
hijacking black lives matter but they
got booed okay you get a bigger butt
white people yeah I did see that video
claiming they're there for black lives
matter yeah and when the black women are
like putting taxes on Amazon has nothing
to do the black lives matter they poo
them down yeah they're crazy these
people do you see the dumpster fire that
lit up no no straight-up literal
dumpster fire and you know what you know
they do I bet you can guess Oh ran away
call the fire department they called the
Seattle Fire Department
you can you please come and put out this
fire here you go my go here you go say
it'll take us out to is that right here
yes all right
our slash Seattle on reddit car tires
slashed now what really why God three
tires slash parked outside my apartment
in West Capitol Hill was this targeted I
don't live that close to protests and
park off street didn't see any other
cars affected I don't think anyone hates
me enough to do this or maybe my
downstairs neighbor because I've been
doing at home HIIT workouts thoughts
happen to anyone else out there do you
think it's random I feel kind of unsafe
now and I'm also not sure about parking
my car there once I get it fixed what do
I do next
have you tried calling the police file
the police report but without cameras
you can't prove anything there you go
have a man so this person doesn't live
in the zone right it's just a good
example of people who
in Capitol Hill who are like help-help
police on being repressed yeah so what
do they do when they have problems it's
like every video we've seen when like
these protesters are throwing stuff and
then a guy jumps out of his car with a
weapon cool the cops call the cops oh
yeah help help that's how you know
they're playing games yeah they're
playing they're playing rebels and
revolutionaries they throw stuff they
yell F the police they put up a big sign
I love this they said you know what this
building is the property of the seattle
people now or something like that like
it always was you know like I don't know
what changed and it was still community
funded right thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you